[Music]
so yesterday we couldn't finish the
project because when we got home it
started raining today is sunny so we're
trying to finish the project today just
to remind you guys
this is the dinosaur that we have at
hand why are you laughing mama
why are you laughing oh I didn't laugh I
was about to yell at her to stop licking
the wood
are you licking the wood she likes it in
the wood like her mom oh
I'm the lucky one
look behind you
all right Picasso's yep what are we
doing so now we gotta make this
put it on here and how what's your
method so what my method is I'm making
little dots so that I can make mistakes
first right so this is gonna be the head
you see that look watch
like you can't yeah look if I go like
this it said connect the dots like this
I want to use a pencil first see see
kind of looks like that already does
that work that good and then you can go
all the way down to like here and then
the belly just gonna be flat because I
want to make it so go here
like this that looks like the letter j
it kind of looks like it right yeah what
do you think you're the artist
am I yeah no you no she's not no she's
not she's not a Quran this goes all the
way down here like this right
oh they've done this and then it comes
up comes back up so it comes all the way
down so maybe here
right yeah
and then it has a little pointy thing at
the end well the way you should do it
you would just draw a grid I know I
don't have time because we're racing
again it's four o'clock yeah I don't
have time I know the right way
and then we gotta buy a tailor what do
you think
that's what I draw
that and then
like that
that's not look like that it doesn't
look like are you serious you think you
do it better who cares just keep going
out of here and then it looks like a
weird heart it looks like a hen see hey
what we all you got to do it looks good
all we gotta do is cut it out and then
put it on here and we do the exact same
thing it does not look like a dinosaur
at all not yet we gotta paint it first
is this did I curve it too much should I
make it less curvy what do you think
monkey
um a lot curvy so should I make it
flatter like connect it here or you
think this is okay
I used to do like this
no but I'm following the little tail at
the end it goes up like that oh yeah
that's correct so should I is this good
or should I make it a little bit flatter
that's good this is good okay
the artist
no I I it's fine you got the eye
it's snack time
supervising right
all right that's it so ready to cut it
then
easy peasy lemon squeezy
okay be right back
I like watching you walk away
all right so during this step of the
project
I am gonna saw this shape what is it a
good monkey
sword a dinosaur out of this wood yeah
yeah yeah and since I don't have any
professional cinching clamp materials
that's what this lovely lady is gonna be
she's gonna be my professional human
clap well I saw it okay
[Music]
but did you buy um what is it sanding no
awesome hey this is
project for a five-year-old okay there's
a lot of blood missions
cooking
oh
yeah
yeah be careful
we're gonna think something's wrong with
you okay
not bad
all right guys we have an update welcome
back to the Quan's wood shop stop
Woodshop stop
looks pretty good right yeah
yeah look is it look at the dinosaurs
don't touch the edges okay because of
this yeah yep good job so now we're
gonna take this exact replica since it's
so accurate
and we're gonna trace it and then
we're gonna cut another piece out monkey
are you ready to trace
yeah so you gotta trace it okay oh God
mama can you hold it for him so that he
uh yeah right here
yep right there so I have to trace all
over you yeah so all you have to do is
hold it against it
too
it's drawn it no no trace the the bottom
one like a ruler like that no no no okay
let me show you you know what a trace I
do if you start from here and then you
you just
got it yep you're holding it yeah there
you go oh just stay close to the stay
close to this
yeah there you go
I'm gonna stick draw this side yeah draw
this like that that's perfect feel it
yep there you go good job
good job okay okay go back again and fix
it now fix it yeah start this way and
then go back the other way yeah try to
color this side yeah I like that there
you go nice perfect yep you don't have
to go hard but you have to feel it yep
good job
nice
that's good oh he skipped it yeah yeah
you skipped it go back go back yep right
there man yeah there you go good job
good job
okay there you go there you go there you
go
oh you missed all of that I miss it go
back over here okay good job thank you
that's perfect okay
you're gonna fall
as much as she wants to deny it this
lady behind me loves me because she saw
me sawing the Landers all this saw this
flying into my eyes going like this and
she was like I love you so much I want
you to protect your beautiful eyes can
you please put on some eye protection
you write about one thing
I'm smart
and that's smart
enough I was like protecting my eyes and
I was like
I hope dies instead of telling you hey
you should put some eye Pro on well I
knew I'm supposed to put eyebrow I'm
probably trying to bro out
now it's time to put it on the saw horse
that we bought how identical is this
perfect they're like I can't tell which
one's which anymore that's not bad
actually for a little quick project like
this
so I got a sawhorse now it's gonna be
the fun part It's gotta drill it onto it
okay
all right monkey man why do you have the
gloves on what's next cause I'm gonna
touch the wood okay so you're gonna
touch the wood what happens with the
wood now
um I don't get Bloomers cool but what
are we doing with the wood do you know
what Papa's doing next yeah she's gonna
drill these into the horses into the
horses
then why is it called The Boro a bra
cause a Burro's not a horse it's a
donkey oh I don't know they call it
that's true huh they should call it saw
donkey
saw ass
maybe maybe this thing is a donkey yeah
without a head how does a donkey what
noise does a donkey make
when you can hold it make sure it's
against it
like this look it's flat got it got it
okay
let me line it up
it's in the right place okay it's lined
up in the right place good job I didn't
go to this splitter nope who is Papa
hold it against it yep like that you'll
be this
light it back later back up hold in
place okay you got it
[Music]
oh it's okay it's okay
there we go the first one that's the
first one good job thank you
okay
yeah hold the tail hold the tail hold
the towel hold that hold it hold the
tail and the butt butt yep
the donkey butt yeah
there we go
okay hold the butt butt again
are you holding the butt butt okay wait
was it Mia out here
yeah I have no idea Mia
[__] oh no okay
all right the first side is done how do
you feel about it monkey what are your
thoughts right now
where are you happy
why are you happy
I have two eyes is that two eyes are you
happy because it was once on a paper and
now it's coming to real life
yeah
I
we're gonna draw the eye on and we got
cool spray paint
with us huh
he's gonna go with us
every time every time
that's your dog
he's all there yeah she's on the side of
that yeah
[Music]
I found Mia uh on the other side of the
neighbor's house so we put her inside
the house and I think she really wants
to be with us but she doesn't want to be
with us I think she just wants to
explore so she like just takes off so
she's crying because she wants to come
out so that she could take off
I don't know what tech is doing it's
okay
okay mister okay okay right there
press it yep
good job that's it because sometimes if
you push too hard this is what it said
I'll go right through it yep there we go
yeah I can go right through the butt and
then boom is out there yep
came out pretty good let me do one more
just thing or two more just in case it
looks like a sheep with its head up
and those are its feet dude this is such
a [__] awesome idea is it you're like
a weird dinosaur because it has donkey
legs so it was a donkey
a donkey chicken
that's a donkey horse
[Music]
all right monkey this is what we got so
far
is it close
to this
no because there's not a tail it's not a
test we have to put that on later but
now this is the tail well this is the
tail right here the little pointy point
the tailbone but we still need to get a
big tower here but now it's the fun part
you know what the fun part is
what is it what is it spring Place
yep it's the Mexican side oh you want to
get ready to take it up
let's go yep
what is that the lady at uh Home Depot
recommended this she goes that's gonna
be way easier for a kid because she
knows the projects together he's like
that's gonna be way easier for a kid to
spray like this versus spray like that
oh let's go get ready to text it hey
so what what do Papa just do right now
[Music]
see okay
we're gonna need special gloves okay
yeah these are too thick
put these on like this
plastic yeah these are plastic ones
which ones are stronger your right hand
or left hand
oh you show me the left hand yeah
you know how to find your fingers
okay good job
all right so I'm gonna Papa's gonna test
it first okay but you get to do it
no I have to test the spray
I feel like I have to read Wait Wait
Don't point the novel at me
no monkeys
oh that's how you do it oh okay perfect
so this is what you're gonna do
you're gonna squeeze it right but keep
your arms straight like this lock it out
and what I want you to do is go I'll
show you in the beginning nice and
smooth if you want long marks okay like
this watch watch pop okay you're
watching
like that long marks okay ready okay
here we go
yeah there you go
welcome arms nice and straight nice and
straight so it's far away from you
because the wind will blow
and I'll come and I'll go on your face
oh God let me move out of the way pause
pause
[Music]
yeah don't touch it okay
yeah that's really good yeah it looks
really good
[Music]
get a little bit closer get a little bit
closer there you go
there you go keep moving keep moving yep
keep moving keep moving
don't look at the nozzle like that okay
keep moving keep moving there you go
side to side set aside
set aside
my mama said to go close yeah because he
was that's your fault no no no no look
I'll show you I'll show you
monkey look so this you look at this you
see on my arms straight
but I can be close right but if you're
like this yeah you're gonna spray your
face so keep your arms locked but you
can still be close or far okay there you
go
keep your arm locked
okay you got that spot now where there's
a wood there you go
good job
what's happening right now all right so
we painted it pretty good
now my stroke remember Maestro me yes
me yeah no that's that's good that's it
okay it's really wet come right here
don't touch it no you know what that's
called it's called attitude
okay now does this look
good so far what do you guys think
[Music]
oh yeah yeah well actually it's flipped
to the other side this is the head yeah
it is that's this you gotta flip it the
other side don't touch it but once it
once it's dries and you can draw the
face look monkey
and the heart this is the green that
they use for special effects so we can
make it totally disappear
Ed are you proud of it monkey do you
like it
oh
I was hoping to get the green Dinosaur
project done by the end of this weekend
but because today is the end of the
weekend it's our wrap-up day so you can
see Mama is mopping
making sure everything is clean we just
gave Mia the best bath for Life Mia come
here come show everyone how clean you
are oh look at that oh look at a fluffy
so we just did that
clean up the kitchen
prep the uh some food made some brussels
sprouts to get ready for the start of
the week organize the fridge because you
can see it was a mess it's already
starting to become a mess of me stuff
away okay yep
and because of that even though the
dinosaur I think is just about dry can I
walk over in this section yeah even
though the dinosaur is just about dry
um I don't think we have time for taika
to draw the face on it and we still have
to put the spikes on the back which is
why we have the plastic but it is
chilling in here oh man and you could CR
you could smell the spray paint like
crazy in here but it's chilling right
here here's the dinosaurs we've still
gotta draw the little triangle spikes
and then we can
um not super glue is it called glue gun
it to the back and then tiger could draw
the funny face over here put a heart
so we're gonna have to end the Vlog here
we try our best uh maybe we'll do a part
two part three if you guys want to see
the final product but ultimately I was
just trying to have some really really
CUNY fun time with tactical because if
you listen to the podcast that we're
talking about like hataka's ADHD
and I was like you know like
when you think about a regular kid
you're like oh if I get my dirt bike
like that would knock him off his boots
you know like that he would love that
but I'm gonna know with the kid with
ADHD that's basic I'm like imagine you
have a dirt bike
or you give a ADHD kid with a bottle of
shampooing we're going to put this in
the fountain and it's going to flood the
whole city with foam and Bubbles the 880
is cheese and like whoa so because of
that I was like a five-year-old using
spray paint
I bet he has never in his like wildest
dreams that think that you can color
things through spring stuff so he had a
blast so he sprayed that whole thing
for a good like 15 minutes I've never
seen him that focused ever so I was
really happy with the way uh the project
came out but thank you guys for watching
and we'll see you guys next time goodbye
Mia